depuis la diffusion du documentaire je
ne suis pas une [ __ ] je suis une
journaliste dimanche soir sur canal+ des
langues se délient j'ai été choqué il ya
un euro sauvion pierre ménès qui venait
s'expliquer sur différents points
d'abord sur une scène face à marie
portolano qui avait été retiré du
montage et que nous vous avons montré en
exclusivité sa par exemple à ce que je
leur ferai aujourd'hui oui soulever la
jupe de quelqu'un comme ça puis sur les
différents extraits de journalistes qui
sont ressorties sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment une scène de baiser avec la
journaliste francesca antoniotti
sur le moment je les ai pas du tout vécu
comme une agression sexuelle sur notre
plateau pierre ménès a d'abord tenu à
présenter ses excuses à toutes les
femmes qu'il aurait pu offenser pour
tout ce qui s'est passé l'âge et des
profonds regrets
cependant il a précisé qu'il regrettait
que l'on vit dans une époque nous ne
peut plus rien faire le monde a changé
j'ai mis tout on peut plus rien faire on
peut plus rien dire sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans les médias nombreuses
ont été les réactions et vous pierre
ménès vous at il convaincu
pierre ménès vous at il convaincu et on
vous pose la question bien sûr chez vous
également merci rokhaya d'être avec nous
merci emilie lopez télé loisirs qu'elle
est voilà je suis là le vendredi aussi
mais vous êtes là le vendredi
oui mais maintenant vous allez tous les
vendredis 4 et les loisirs
emilie vache qui rit quand ça m'a alors
dit nous vous est ce qui vous a
convaincu pierre ménès mois déjà je vais
dire que j'ai un peu le cul entre deux
chaises
parce que pierre c'est un ami depuis 15
ans oui que la majorité des journalistes
qui interviennent dans le documentaire
sont des copines voir des amis qu'en
tant que femme c'est vrai que voilà il
ya des choses qui sont un peu
compliquées ce que je peux dire c'est
que c'est que c'est que pierre s'est
excusé alors on l'entend pas aujourd'hui
mais il a présenté des excuses sur sur
votre plateau alors certains diront que
c'est un peu tard mais j'ai envie de
dire mieux vaut tard que jamais et je
trouve qu'en fait là la situation est en
train de complètement débordé savent
qu'en fait on parle plus du tout de la
force du documentaire de marie paletou
l'anneau encore plus qu'hier et je
trouve ça un peu dommage parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui devraient être mises
en lumière et plein de bourreau et en
fait on n'en parle pas du tout et je
trouve ça dommage ça met en lumière
quand même les mêmes gens qui s'y sont
intéressés il ya plein de gens qui ont
le regard qu'ils ont regardé rokhaya
diallo alors moi je tiens à dire toute
ma solidarité
envers les personnes qui ont courage de
s'exprimer envers les femmes qui ont le
courage de s'exprimer je trouve que
effectivement le documentaire de marie
porte-là nous avait déjà été victime de
comportements sexistes de harcèlement de
mecs relou qui vous envoie des dards ça
faisait des remarques sexistes oui des
remarques sexistes des comportements
sexistes ici ici communion ici pas
particulièrement mais c'est quelque
chose qui expérimentent vraiment souvent
est vraiment un peu partout donc que des
phrases désagréable mais que ça toi vous
est-ce que les excuses de pire menace
hier
et quand il dit je vois là et qu'il
regrettait qui méritent un peu tout ce
qui lui arrive est ce que vous les
acceptez ce que vous vous dites
bon on passe à autre chose ou est ce que
pour vous ça vous suffit pas alors moi
honnêtement j'ai été scandalisé vraiment
d'accord mans par le dispositif c'est à
dire que moi ce que je trouve important
c'est que la parole des victimes
puissent s'exprimer et pour moi c'est
elle qui mérite toute l'attention
ce qui est important c'est vraiment
l'ordre il ya eu le documentaire devient
celle réponse aux besoins alimentaires
je l'entends après mois ce qui va
choquer dans l'attitude de pierre ménès
que je connais beaucoup moins que
plusieurs d'entre vous c'est la manière
dont en fait il était centré sur lui
c'est à dire qu'il est vraiment venu en
disant qu'il avait passé une mauvaise
journée sans aucune pensée pour toutes
les femmes qui avait été traumatisée par
cette attitude quand même son attitude a
fait l'objet de plusieurs témoignages de
témoignages ou multiple le fait qu' il
explique que finalement ce qu'il
regrette c'est qu'on ait changé d'époque
et que mis tout ça correspond à on ne
peut plus rien dire
non me tout c'est la peau c'est la
possibilité pour des femmes de
s'exprimer alors qu'à lille ddd des
violences sexuelles et des violences
sexuelles et sexistes donc le fait de
réduire mis tout à sa personne au fait
que ça l' entrave dans la possibilité
qu'il avait malheureusement de de
perpétrer des agressions parce que moi
ce que j'ai vu ce sont des agressions
sexuelles
les agressions sexuelles s'est
caractérisée par la loi il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui disent que voilà j'ai
nombreuses copies nos téléphones qui
m'ont dit qu'on avait été trop sympa
avec lui parce qu'ils n'ont pas jeté
tout en vous tenez voilà je mets
nettement moi j'ai trouvé que c'était
vraiment j'ai eu l'impression de voir
une opération de réhabilitation c'est à
dire que j'ai eu le sentiment qu'on
avait construit un espace pour lui
permettre pour leur est alors je vous
dirais que j'ai dit toute la vérité
rocailleux on est très pote un recueil à
moi bien sûr voilà
vraiment je le dis on nous ment par
rokhaya j'ai dit toute la vérité
prochaine et pas eu pire menace au
téléphone m'ont matin je n'ai pas eu du
tout de toute la journée jeux les rues
ici j'ai eu je vous raconte tout parce
qu'on entend tout et n'importe quoi sur
ce qui s'est passé je vous racontais on
est dimanche soir donc voilà il ya le
match lyon psg et j'appelle le directeur
des programmes d'antenne des antennes de
canal+
gérald brice viret je lui dis qu'est ce
qui se passe autour de pierre ménès
je vois que sur twitter ça on çà çà çà
bouge beaucoup me dit oui voilà oui mais
voilà c'est au sujet de savait que le
documentaire qui est passé de mari
portolano on est très fiers de ce
documentaire et j'étais très heureux de
l'avoir fait giuly ils ont tout de suite
dit oui
thierry cheleman le directeur de sport
était comme un putsch de ce documentaire
ils m'ont appelé je vous dis ça fait des
semaines et des semaines qu'ils
m'appellent qui me dit cyril on faire
enfin super documentaire voilà sur canal
+ on espère que tu reprendras des images
derrière et que tu en parlera donc tout
se passe bien et là je leur dis mais
pourquoi je vous dis la vérité si mais
pourquoi vous avez pu couper des
séquences et là je vous jure il me dit
non on a et essaient vraiment on a pris
le parti de couper toutes les
interventions d1 masculine parce que
c'était un choix éditorial
je vous dis vraiment la vérité gibbons
d'accord et je lui dis qu'est ce qu'il
fait pour ya une séquence qui fait
polémique qui a été coupée je lui ai dit
écoute moi je pense que demain n'en
touche pas à mon poste il faut
absolument passer cette séquence voilà
il me dit écoute je vais voir il me dit
d'aller d'accord vas-y pas cela parce
que d'un bout d'un bon sentiment
parce que c'est vrai que cette c mine de
rien comme l'a dit émilie ce
documentaire il est magnifique et il ya
plein de gens qui voulaient le voir et
qu'ils ont vu d'ailleurs et qui est qui
et c'est devenu pour canal+ un gros
problème alors que il avait tout fait
pour faire ce documentaire et qui est
qu'à la base est magnifique donc c'est
vrai que ça leur passe alors retombe
dessus
derrière on dit que pierre wenes et
protégé alors je vous le dis pire mais s
est pas du tout protégé où j'ai vu qu'il
on disait qu'il était meilleur ami de
l'actionnaire de canal plus je vous le
dis ils se connaissent pas du tout sont
venus trois fois il n'est pas du tout
meilleurs amis voilà de l'actionnaire ou
de rien du tout de ça je peux le jurer
mais vraiment n'importe quoi donc on
entend tout et n'importe quoi on dit
qu'il est
convoqué par la direction de canal+
c'est faux il ya juste le matin il ya la
directrice de la communication qui l'a
appelée qui lui a dit il faut qu'on
fasse quelque chose il faut que tu te
faut que tu parles d'opéra 10 moi je
fais ce que vous voulez vous me dites
que je fais et je le ferai
voilà c'est tout et derrière j'ai dit
écoutez moi je pense que le mieux c'est
qu'ils viennent s'exprimer dans touche
pas à mon poste c'est l'émission la plus
puissante du groupe
forcément il faut qu'il vienne ici donc
j'ai dit à la directrice de la com
il faut qu'il vienne ne touche pas à mon
poste et au patron de canal+ il m'a dit
bah écoute il viendra dans touche pas à
mon poste ce soir parce que lui aussi
maintenant il veut s'exprimer
et voilà donc je te le dis il n'y a pas
de mensonge le truc moi tout est clair
en fait moi ce qui m'a vraiment gêné et
c'est vraiment en tant que femme c'est
de me dire que j'avais l'impression
qu'ils ne mesuraient pas la gravité de
ceux des accusations dont il faisait
l'objet et qui sont documentés c'est à
dire qu'on a vu les vidéos et que lui
disent on a changé d'époque c'est plus
acceptable ça n'a jamais tué près stable
ça tu fais accepte acceptable en fait
aujourd'hui c'est moins assez moins
accepté parce que les femmes ont
davantage l'espace pour s'exprimer mais
rochus est décédé des rames en fait il
ya cinq ans où il ya dix ans moi je
prends la défense juste de canal+ c'est
mon groupe
voilà et je pense que voilà aujourd'hui
moi j'étais fier qui est un documentaire
comme ça et là directeur des sports et
la direction de cada puce fassent un
documentaire comme ça c'est surtout
avant un très gros match psg lyon
j'ai trouvé que c'était génial et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'à cause de
cette polémique
ça peut gâcher nos meilleurs en fait moi
j'ai été gêné par une forme de
déséquilibre c'est à dire qu'à par
géraldine qui l'a interpellée en lui
disant que c'était quand même pas lui la
victime qu'ils viennent en plateau pour
être dire sa première phrase et j'ai
passé une mauvaise journée
la décence pour moi c'est quand même de
penser aux femmes qui ont souffert qui
ont été humiliés par son attitude et en
plus plusieurs femmes se sont exprimés
en dehors du documentaire donc un moment
donné je pense que le minimum c'est
vraiment de faire profil bas et de
reconnaître qu'on a créé un dommage et
se remettre en question et où que ça a
manqué